le président gbagbo est parti dans un
déshonneur qui était totale et
aujourd'hui il revient avec des honneurs
qui lui sont refusés
même s'il rentre en tant qu' en tant
qu'ancien chef d'état c'est lui qui a
donné les premiers coups de boutoir pour
obtenir la libéralisation de la vie
politique en côte d'ivoire
c'est un animal politique il n'a jamais
oublié qu'il était un homme politique
la plus grande victime ici c'est la
nation ivoirienne parce que elle est
très divisée aujourd'hui il ya peu de
chances que en restant sur le logiciel
actuel les ivoiriens se réconcilient
je pense qu'en faisant cette conjoncture
d'évènements favorables avec le
ministère de la réconciliation et le
retour de laurent gbagbo il devrait y
avoir un début de réconciliation
nationale